um I have a question from this lady here
um just correct me if in case I
understood drawing you said that men are
more clever than women have I heard it
correctly exactly okay how you can
um how you can prove that they have very
big difficult medical things when
approvement taxes to part of brain and
show The Logical way for example if men
play chess he can play 10 steps they
make the same experiment with women can
be maximum five your brain not have
deepest level which have meant it's
approved it's approved if you're
interested it means IQ it's man IQ it's
meant how deep he can make if you take
all statistic woman we cook every day
but chefs is always man so